the New York Times book review list of
the top 10 Pamela Paul is the book
review editor and she joins us now to
break down the top picks uh Pamela good
morning thank you so much for joining us
uh I did see a graphic novel on the list
are people still reading books let's
just start with that they are still
reading books and I'm so relieved you're
not asking me about Russian rubles um
there is a graphic novel on the cover uh
among our top 10 it is can't we talk
about something more pleasant by Ros
Chast which is a graphic Memoir about
her dealing with with her two aging
parents and ultimately their deaths it
was also a nominee for the national book
award and the only nominee by a woman
and it's interesting because this is the
most recent of several books that have
dealt with aging parents I think a sign
that the baby boomers are reaching this
point in their lives I want to talk
about uh the book redeployment by Phil
clay he's a Marine who served in Iraq
and you know my father was a career
marine and I know that he and his
friends from the service have been
emailing these short stories around it's
incredibly powerful has enough time pass
to start seeing War literature I think
so and we've seen a few in the last uh
couple years there's some more coming
out this spring Phil kly book
redeployment it's a group it's a
collection of short stories and he is a
former Marine um one of several Kevin
power recently also wrote a book called
the yellow birds um which was one of our
top 10 a couple of years ago um but I
think what's amazing about Phil cly's uh
book is that it deals with both soldiers
you know in Iraq and also when they come
back here and that that that rotation I
I'm fascinated by what's not on the list
my book of the Year hands down is Henry
Kissinger's world order a guy named W
Mel who's he's between jobs no idea who
you're talking about between jobs right
now I thought he gave it a very nice
balanced
review um of its Pro pros and cons how
do you pick the books it's very hard you
know this year it is true that what's
notable is what's missing there are no
huge door stop uh books on this year's
best non-fiction so last year there were
a huge number of books on World War I a
number of books on the financial did you
ever pick Harry Potter does that make
the list or is that just beneath you
well we have a children's book list so
nothing is beneath that's that's where
she put the kiss in your book yeah I
have to say when Tom brings up John
nichel our new boss what he's actually
saying is I for one welcome our new
English over exactly that had a mistaked
whiff of brown nosing um there was a
book on there called immunity do you
think that got a boost from Ebola you
know it's interesting I think that that
um the book is by ulis and it's really
an extended essay about um vaccines and
all of our fears around vaccines and our
fears around science and sort of what
causes anxiety with new parents our fear
that there's something toxic out there
and I do think that that the Ebola fear
may have played into it kind of hit at a
at a very uh good moment I will tell you
one of these books that I read with
Terror which is uh the um the sixth
Extinction from Elizabeth Colbert
Colbert Colbert Colbert um was uh
terrifying book it is yeah um Al Gore
reviewed it for us on our cover and um
she basically by the sixth Extinction
she's talking about the mass extinction
of species and there have been five
previous in our history luckily way
before we came uh on the scene um but
that we're basically going to see about
20 to 50% of the species currently on
the planet die off about 24 months ago I
AG aggressively went back to reading
hard cover books within your world and
your expertise what's the trend right
now Kindle wins book industry wins how's
it how's it work well you're talking to
a partisan here but but I think when you
look at the trends in terms of of tablet
reading there was a steep increase and
then it's kind of leveled off it's still
increasing but I think that what's
happening is that even people who are
reading on e-readers they're they're
sort of toggling between formats so they
might take the e-reader when they travel
on business they want to car
uh Lisa where are you I'm e I'm I'm an e
reader E I don't I think it's clutter
I'm sorry I'm like this is Blasphemous
but I think that honestly I think that I
have so much stuff I don't want all the
books collecting dust I would rather
just read the books on a TBL all the
books I buy them in hard cover and I
stack them next to my bed so that I can
never read them that's where Thomas
Pet's capital is right now on top of the
because the death the death of radio has
been predicted for a million years and
it hasn't happened and the death of book
you live with it every day right video
didn't kill the Radio Star don't change
the thing this is the first thing let me
have this let me let's my book was the
gold fin this is the first thing I do
Sunday this was I thought you suay don't
you go buy a bagel or something jump in
go through the weddings Tom scouring the
wedding announcements it's time Brandon
hold that thought for our Twitter
question of the day we asked you what is
your book of First winners Dream by Bill
mcdermit CEO of sap that was my book of
the Year # inspiration uh we also got
Ken fet's edge of Eternity hands down
the best book of the year no one else
humanizes history as well as he does and
finally Brendon mentioned it capital
Thomas petti or M petti he answered some
important questions but left enough room
for further Inquisition I saw Pet's book
even made Bill Gates top books of the
years he says he does disagree with some
of the conclusions did anybody read it
made some very interesting points Pam
why are none of those books on your list
you know not every book can make it uh
but I don't know if people have read it
is there a lot of yelling and screaming
about uh when you guys pick the list
there's always yes there's always
complaining which bar do you pick this
in I'm sorry which bar do you pick this
in yeah that's right we all just we just
roll uh you know it's all a gamble
that's great result of a
drinking do you have a book do you have
a book shop you go to I go to many book
shops yeah I go to um uh you know I
still go to Barnes & Noble um I go to
books of wonder which is a local uh book
for children for my kids I go to the
Strand um and I love uh there's some
great bookstores outside the city
politics and pros and Washington is a
book the maple leaf bookstore in New
Orleans